so are we ready to reopen the country
let's talk with Louisiana Congressman
Mike Johnson he happens to be a member
of the opening up America again
congressional group he is a Republican
and it's good to have you back with us
congressman hey Shannon great to see you
okay so let's talk about how some of
this is gonna go down Steny Hoyer who's
the top democrat or excuse me the second
Democrat over there in the house says
this the administration has failed to
implement a comprehensive testing regime
and continues to dodge responsibility to
lead in this crisis now saying that
states must come up with their own way
of producing the tens of millions of
tests required that's a shocking
abdication of the president's duty to
the American people so congressman
what's your understanding about the
availability of tests whether it's on
States the feds how is this working or
not working well what's shocking but my
first reaction is what's shocking is
that Democrats in Congress want to
politicize this when this is no time for
politics we all need to be pulling
together and the president is doing that
with these task forces communicating
directly with the governor's and has he
told us on a conference call yesterday
morning almost all the governors are
cooperating with him very well because
we know we have to solve this crisis
testing is not the end-all be-all as
your opening segment they're just
Illustrated the administration is doing
everything they can this is a historic
unprecedented ramp up in what in all
these supplies that are needed and as
you just said there'll be seventeen
million more swab test added to the
tests that are already out there in the
next 30 to 45 days so that the federal
government is doing everything it
possibly can and I think it's
appropriate to look to the governor's in
the state's
under our system of federalism to step
up in to help and to make some of these
decisions on the ground level they'll
have the equipment they need and as the
president said you heard him say it
himself if they don't have what they
need we'll help them get it and that's
all really you could ask of Washington
well you know his critics were very
upset that he said he had authority to
make these decisions about opening and
closing and now the plan that he's
rolled out to many people seems very
reasonable there is criteria it's
data-driven it does now give authority
to governor's to make the best decisions
for their states but critics including
the man who wants to unseat him and take
his job former Vice President Joe Biden
says I don't
this a plan I think what he's done he's
punted he's decided that he's not now he
doesn't have the right to make the calls
for the country so too authoritarian now
punting what do you think is a fair
assessment of what the president's done
I think Joe Biden would criticize
President Trump whatever he did it would
be wrong and he's armchair
quarterbacking and he has the luxury of
doing that President Trump on the other
hand has the responsibility of leading
this nation and and I think most
Americans appreciate what he's done
leading with authority and conviction
and being accessible to everyone he's
out there every single day completely
transparent and what he's doing I think
it was it was realistic and right for
him to acknowledge that this has to be a
state-by-state decision there's not a
one-size-fits-all here even within
states like my state of Louisiana we've
been hit pretty hard by this pandemic
but but what may be necessary in New
Orleans for a reopening protocol it may
not be the same for where I live in
Northwest Louisiana so there there has
to be that decision made by those on the
ground at the local and state level
there are the only ones that can
accurately access that data and I think
that's what the president's saying I
think most people understand that that's
realistic and that's what has to happen
you have had a really rough time of it
down in the New Orleans area
I mean Louisiana has had real strains on
your medical resources down there and
the good people have been struggling
quite a bit with that there have been
tornados through the south there been
all kinds of things that you guys have
had to deal with in the meantime Pew
Research is looking into people's
attitudes how they're feeling about
these ideas of reopening when they were
asked about concerns on restrictions on
public activity concerns they'd be
lifted to quickly 66% not quickly enough
32% how we talked about this a little
bit last night but how do you regain the
confidence of the American consumer out
there whether they feel good about
sending their kids back out or going to
a restaurant when those appropriate
times come state-by-state how do you
reach your Americans that they will be
safe where they won't participate in the
economy in the way that we need them to
yeah this will be a real test for our
institutions and and this is when we
need sound leadership we need steady
hands at the wheel at the local state
and of course at the federal level you
know the president's put out the
guidelines since these these three phase
protocol and steps to get back to some
sense of normalcy we're all eager to do
that we understand we have to because
Shannon you know and we've all been
talking about this idea that we hit a
point of diminishing returns on this
very soon you know if public health is
going to be the driving force behind
this and it should be you you have to
realistically look at this if you keep
things closed down too long that has a
terrible long-term effect on public
health it leads more people into poverty
and it leads to record levels of
unemployment that could be sustained so
those are all the factors that have to
be considered here we want to open the
economy soon that's what's going to make
people feel confident again when they
see things getting back to normal what's
normal again that's going to spur on
more activity it's going to give people
dignity in their work when they go back
to work and when we can get the kids
back to school and and large venues
reopen and people back at church now I
think that they'll they'll they'll feel
a growing sense of confidence about
what's happening we have to do that
sooner than later and I think everybody
recognizes that yeah well we're all
pulling for you folks down there in
Louisiana and for the house as you try
to put together an agreement on some
further funding for small businesses
that desperately need it
Congressman Mike Johnson good to have
you thank you thanks Shannon